البحث عن ماوى امن حاجه بشريه منذ الازل
لكن منازلنا قد تصبح من الذ اعدائنا هذا
ما حدث مع السيده مزين بالسعر
كان المنزل يهتز وكان الارض تزحف من تحت
اقدامنا لم يكن بمقدورنا التحرك بدات
الاشياء تتساقط علينا حاولنا الهرب لكن
الباب لم يفتح لان المبنى كان قد انحرف
بشكل كبير
خلال جولاتنا في المدن المنكوبه لاحظنا
ابنيه ملتويه بفعل الضرر لكنها تحتفظ
بسلامه نسبيه فيها ياكلها الخارجيه بينما
انهارت اخرى بشكل كامل
يرجع خبراء الجيولوجيا تفوت الضرر في
المناطق المنكوبه الى هندسه البناء
والمواد المستخدمه التي تجعل مبنى مقاوما
واخر غير مقاوم للزلزال
العنصر الاول هو التربه فان كانت قابله
للتشبع بالمياه في حال حدوث حركه تكتونيه
فهذا يعني ان الارض في لحظه الزلزال
ستتحول الى قاعده هلاميه يتحرك معها
المبنى تحرك المبنى يحدث شقوقا في اعمده
الاساس فيلتوي البناء وهذه لحظه حاسمه اما
ان ينهار في حال عدم التنبه لمعايير
السلامه او يميل ان كانت المعايير غير
مكتمله او يبقى صامضا يعني
الهندسه الحديثه البناء في اي مكان في
المناطق المعرضه للزلزال يتم بناء اوتاد
عميقه ثم تبنى اساسات المبنى وتثبت احيانا
يتهرب المتعهدون من هذه الحلول لانها تزيد
قليلا في كلفه البناء
في حاله تركيا تقول السلطات ان من اسباب
الضرر الكبير عدم الالتزام بالمعايير
الدقيقه في البناء لا سيما في فتره ما قبل
عام 2000
غالبيه المباني التي تدمرت في الكارثه
الاخيره وبنسبه
98% شيدت قبل العام
لهذا بدات السلطات ملاحقه واسعه لمتعهدي
بناء يشتبه في اهمالهم متطلبات البناء
الامن بانتظار انتهاء التحقيقات الرسميه
اذا ستشكل هذه الكارثه منعطفا اساسيا في
مرحله التعافي منها وستكون محاسبه
المقصرين ركنا بارزا فيها
لا يمكن منع وقوع الكوارث الطبيعيه يقول
خبراء لكن بالطبع يمكن للتطور البشري اي
يخفف من الماس التي تنتج عنها بطريقه
بسيطه ان تاتي معايير السلامه اولا ودائما